There is a universe of small molecules hidden in plain sight.
The small molecules are beautiful structures
and it allows us to think about really the beauty of nature.
My name is Jason Crawford and I'm a chemical biologist.
I'm the director of the Institute of Biomolecular Design and Discovery
on the West Campus.
And our mission is to employ chemical biology
to solve problems in human health.
Chemical biology, by definition, is interdisciplinary.
The West Campus, its mission is to promote interdisciplinary science.
And I just love getting people with different mindsets
all in the same room and thinking about a common goal.
We focus on the basic science of cellular physiology,
how the molecules regulate cellular processes.
And what is fascinating is that if you look at any cell,
whether it's a microbe or a human tissue,
greater than 90% of the molecules in those cells remain unknown.
So a big part of our group is to parse apart the junk
from the molecules that represent novel metabolic pathways.
And if you can decode a novel metabolic
pathway, this opens completely new doors
for a wide variety of directions,
including preclinical drug development.
So one of the guiding principles of our lab
is to decode these metabolic pathways and understand
how microbes can alter human physiology.
We look at specific responses like how do the microbes
regulate inflammation
and how do they damage your DNA,
which can be linked to colorectal cancer?
I try to encourage my students to tackle problems from multiple angles.
Of course, give them feedback as we go.
But really, my job
is to help them with the big picture
and push goals at a thematic level.
Chemical biology at Yale spans
Yale's West Campus
The Faculty of Arts and Sciences on the main campus
and the Yale School of Medicine.
We try to collaborate to promote the best science at Yale.
I'm just truly fascinated by this area
and I can't imagine doing anything else with my career.